cette semaine quelle est ta vision de
l'auto futurisme alors pour répondre à
la question 2001 et sarah quelle est ma
vision dans le fond d'un futur
autochtone je pense que j'étais beaucoup
inspiré par le film black panther où on
voyait de l'afro futurisme et jeu quand
j'ai vu ce film là pour la première fois
je me suis dit ah ça serait à ce serait
l'fun de voir justement au lieu de voir
des publicités ou des immeubles qui sont
uniquement inspiré par je dirais une
vision eurocentré de 2,2 de la présence
humaine
on prévoit des design plus en tipi en
wigwam des maisons aux longues et là on
le voit de plus en plus par rapport à
des buildings vaut 1 construit dans les
communautés mais là on parle du futur on
parle d'avoir un futur autochtone est ce
ce qui est drôle c'est que la seule
manière qu'on peut même envisager qu'un
futur redeviennent autochtone c'est à
travers soi une grande catastrophe
climatique et où une invasion de zombies
d'ailleurs il ya un film que je veux
aller voir absolument c'est blood quoi
homme qui parle justement de
l'apocalypse zombie mais vu des
premières nations
alors ça c'est intéressant parce qu'on
voit comment j'étais très inquiète à une
catastrophe ou
des zombies peuvent rééquilibrer
justement la chance que les premières
nations auraient de redevenir une
population qui aurait sa place même une
place centrale
donc c'est certain que j'ai une vision
d'avenir d'autres ça mais je vois pas
tant une vision de prise de pouvoir
comme on peut en parler aujourd'hui mais
de rééquilibre des rôles de rééquilibre
de la vie en communauté
alors comment je dirigeais une vision de
l'avenir ce serait de revenir avec des
valeurs comme une honte a beaucoup plus
solide
un leadership traditionnel ça doit pas
un leadership du 99 % ceux qui
soutiennent un pour ça des leaders mais
plutôt le contraire ce qu'on voyait
autrefois c'est à dire les leaders qui
soutiennent la communauté je verrai
aussi un avenir qui repend serait
justement sa présence sur le territoire
pas uniquement dans les grandes villes
mais dans le territoire au complet et
reprendre et je dis pas possession comme
d'un objet mais reprendre notre place
dans ce territoire leur reprendre le nom
les toponymie de chaque endroit dans la
forêt pour se rendre compte qu'on a eu
on ne fuit une grande partie de nos
territoires qu'on le voit encore comme
un frigidaire de ressources alors dans
le futur je le verrais plutôt comme on
habite les boisés les forêts les
montagnes de la même manière que nos
ancêtres le faisais et donc on garde en
tête toujours comment la santé de cette
forêt leveaux et notre rôle notre
responsabilité et tu vois est plus
positif que destructif est beaucoup plus
court beaucoup plus inclusif aussi parce
que ça doit être participatif avec
toutes les populations qui sont sur ces
territoires l'eau donc cette
responsabilité doit être partagée et ça
c'est mon rêve pour un futur autochtone
j'espère avons pu il répond à votre
question et j'espère que vous allez nous
en envoyer d'autres à paroles autochtone
je souhaite une belle semaine